كان من المعروف بالفعل أن
التعرض المتكرر للصراع والعنف،
بما في ذلك مشاهدة وتجربة
هدم المساكن جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الحصار الإسرائيلي لغزة منذ عام
2007 يرتبط بمستويات عالية من
الضيق النفسي بين
الفلسطينيين، وقد أعرب
قرار مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة رقم 2712 عن
قلقه العميق من أن
التعطيل  إن الوصول إلى التعليم له
تأثير كبير على الأطفال، وللصراع
تأثير مدى الحياة على
صحتهم الجسدية والعقلية. ومن
المهم وضع أعمال الإبادة الجماعية
في السياق الأوسع
لسلوك إسرائيل تجاه الفلسطينيين خلال فترة انفصالها التي
دامت 75 عامًا، أي
56 عامًا  الاحتلال العسكري الطويل
للأراضي الفلسطينية
والحصار الطويل الذي يفرضه على قطاع
غزة منذ 16 عامًا، بما في ذلك الانتهاكات الخطيرة والمستمرة
للقانون الدولي
المرتبطة به، بما في ذلك
الانتهاكات الجسيمة لاتفاقية جنيف الرابعة،
وتشمل هذه الشروط الطرد من
المنازل والتشريد الجماعي إلى جانب
التدمير واسع النطاق للمنازل والممتلكات.
المناطق السكنية أعرب خبراء الأمم المتحدة
أيضًا عن
قلقهم العميق إزاء فشل
النظام الدولي في التعبئة
لمنع الإبادة الجماعية ضد الفلسطينيين،
ودعوا
المجتمع الدولي إلى بذل كل ما في وسعه للتصدي الفوري
لخطر الإبادة الجماعية ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني.